[MUSIC PLAYING]
EUGENE YEH: Hello,
everyone, thanks for coming.
My name's Eugene Yeh.
I lead the GROWTH team
with an Android Enterprise.
That's basically everyone
who's out in the field
helping partners and
customers, like yourselves, be
successful with Android
in the enterprise space.
With me today is Nisha
Sharma who's with Accenture.
And we're here to talk
to you a little bit
about how Android is
disrupting the enterprise
space with mobility.
There's always a good and bad
about being in the latter half
of the conference.
The bad part, obviously,
is you've absorbed
a lot of this information.
And you want to be in
the front because you
have a lot of energy when you're
coming into the conference,
and you're taking
a lot of notes.
And then you get
to the back half,
you're like, oh, overloaded.
But the good news is,
honestly, as you're now
processing all the things you've
heard about for the last two
or three days and
incorporating that
into what you're supposed to
be doing back at the office,
you're now realizing,
oh, I've got to go back.
And how am I supposed to use all
these things in the priorities
that I had set just
like two months ago
at the beginning of the year?
And this is really
good context for us
to talk about
Android Enterprise,
because a lot of folks are
thinking about mobility not
as a standalone thing but
in the context of what
you're trying to do more
broadly within your business.
And not surprisingly, when we
go and talk to organizations,
a lot of organizations
are well on their way
of deploying what they would
term as digital transformation
technologies.
However, when you
think about that
more broadly in the
context of the capabilities
of the organization, you begin
to run into a lot of problems.
And I know when you
hear about more broadly
within the conference,
a lot of that
are kind of on-premise
technologies versus cloud
and things like that.
But even more core to
this is the ability
to deliver a lot of these
capabilities to mobility.
And when you think
about the fact
that 41% of the
organizations don't have wall
to wall mobility, that's
kind of a problem.
When you think
about IoT, when you
think about the new
things from analytics,
the ability to
have that knowledge
at the edge of your workforce
and with your customers
is incredibly important.
The idea that you have
to manage supply chains,
that you have to
manage intelligence
without having an
endpoint out there
of some type from a
mobility perspective
makes it very difficult for
you to both build applications
and be successful
in your business.
Because at this point, mobility
or even web technologies,
they're just a thin
veneer to your business.
They are the interface
for both your customers
and your employees to
access all the capabilities
that you've been building
within your organization.
Mobility is actually
how people take action.
It's how people will then
leverage those capabilities
you've built.
You've built on GCP,
you've built on your on-premise
premise technologies.
All of these things
are capabilities
that you need an actual
device to then get access to.
And so an example
of this is smart
manufacturing, or more
broadly speaking, just
distribution channels.
This affects retail customers.
This affects
manufacturing customers.
It affects all the
folks in industrial.
An example specifically for us--
Marks and Spencers'
customer of ours
that faces this
challenge as well--
in that you have to
manage your supply chain,
as I talked about before.
But if you are folks in the
field, your task workers,
your people who are out actually
in the distribution centers
don't have a mobile device
as part of your platform,
you have a challenge, that
they can't scale the barcode,
if you can't get real time
inventory information,
you have difficulty.
And people are trying to find
ways around this with RFID
and other capabilities
with sensors.
But ultimately, you have to
have your workers be enabled.
So the question
then becomes, why
haven't we done this before?
Everyone kind of
intuitively understands
that in order for
me to be effective,
I need a very mobile
workforce, and I
need everyone in my realization
to be mobile capable.
However, what ends
up happening is
you slip you select a
subset of your organization
to have these capabilities.
You say, oh, the folks at
headquarters, the knowledge
workers, the C
level folks, these
are the people who really,
really need to have this.
And what ends up happening is
you have this isolated group
that has mobile capabilities.
But when they try to
take action against it,
you're limited in your tool set.
You don't have the ability
to actually communicate
this to the people who are
doing the work, who are out
in the field.
And you end up in a situation
where you're challenged.
And so it's not it's not like
people don't want to do this,
they're limited.
And you think about why.
We think quite a bit about why,
why hasn't this proliferated?
And the answers
aren't surprising.
It's security, it's
manageability, it's cost.
These are all the reasons
why, as much as I'd
love to have the person
who's checking the meter out
in the field have
this technology, wow,
I don't really have
a good scalable
way by which to manage this.
So we spend a ton of energy
here at Google trying to help
think through that so that
you don't have this challenge
and you actually have the
tools necessary to leverage
the capabilities
that you've heard
about for the last few days.
And this is a
conversation that you
hear about quite a bit with
almost any enterprise software.
You think about the constituents
within your organization
that you need to get
over the line in order
to actually be successful.
There's IT, there's
your line of business,
and there's your employee.
I think it varies depending
on the type of technology
you're talking about,
the level of control,
the level of desire
of each organization
to push forward technology.
But these are all incredibly
important constituents.
And historically,
a lot of folks have
thought about this
as the tug of war,
and I have to make this trade.
I'll give you a very
specific example, security.
So IT obviously wants
an incredibly locked
down environment, because they
don't want any data leakage,
they don't want any compromise
within that ecosystem.
However, the end user
doesn't want that lockdown.
I personally have
had this experience,
I'm sure some of
you have as well.
You get a device, it is
so incredibly locked down
that you can't actually use it.
You shove it in your
drawer, and then
you actually have shadow IT.
You have a problem where people
are bringing their own device
and their own services.
And they circumvent that
control that you thought
was so fantastic.
So beyond that,
when you think even
beyond that to the
line of business,
you think about the person who's
leading marketing, the person
who's leading distribution
and supply chain,
someone who actually
then has to manage that,
if that organization
is so locked down
and their employees aren't
using that mobile device,
their application
actually is unsuccessful.
Right?
At the end, a very
concrete example--
if you have
Salesforce and nobody
is updating it
because the only way
you can access it is
this purpose-built device
that no one wants to use, that
tool isn't actually useful
for you.
So what we think
about then is, how
do I help security
be top of mind
but yet allow the end
user and line of business
the flexibility to
leverage that platform?
So when we think about that, we
came up with the work profile.
So rather than have a very
binary choices to lock down
your device or not, we
partition the device
into a workset of
applications and experiences,
and then you have a
personal set of experiences.
And what that allows you to
do then is rather than have
two separate devices
of which maybe I
have work applications
on my personal device
and personal applications
in my work device
or I don't use the work device
at all, I'm now in a situation
where I have this
one device where
I have comfort in knowing
that IT is not monitoring
my personal use, and yet, I
have a very secure container
within the phone that IT is
very comfortable then deploying
very specific work
applications that
don't bleed data back and
forth between the two profiles.
So that is an example
that when we fundamentally
think bottoms up
at Google of how
to solve the problem of
proliferating mobility
throughout your enterprise, we
actually designed the solution
to meet that need versus
trying to work our way back
from a feature set.
So this applies
across all the needs
that when we think about
an IT organization trying
to think through
security and management,
and we think about employees
thinking about privacy
and well-being, and we think
about lines of business that
actually want to
ensure that they have
a platform under
which they can be
successful with
their transformation,
we focus on all of these things.
And in order for
us to do that, we
think both about the ecosystem,
as well as the things
that Google controls.
So the ecosystem
for Google-- we're
very much about
an open ecosystem,
consistent from
Android Enterprises
to all the technologies
that you've
heard about over the past week.
However, we understand that
there are minimum needs
that we need consistency
around in order
to ensure that the base level
concerns that an enterprise has
are met.
And so we think
through Google Play,
we think through hardware, we
think through the operating
system, and the ecosystem
can customize around that.
But there are very
core components
that don't compromise security
when you try to deploy this
within the enterprise.
What this allows us to do
is you now have security,
you now have a
flexible platform,
but you also have a
variety of form factors to,
again, think through all of
the needs of your organization.
If you're trying
to deploy mobility
across your organization,
if you think
you have a mining platform
out in the Bering Sea,
you can't use a very high cost
device that's very fragile.
It just doesn't work.
However, you want that to
be part of your platform
when you have knowledge
workers in your organization.
You don't want to have
islands of devices
that you're managing separately.
So when we think about the
platform and the ability
to go end-to-end from
smartphones and knowledge
workers out to signage,
a point-of-sale system,
out to virtual reality,
that allows an organization
to actually deploy once, think
through the entire platform,
and actually build on top of it.
And when you have that,
we're able to unlock
a lot of the tools that
you've been hearing about,
again, in the past week.
You now are able to leverage ML.
You're now able to leverage
development tools that allow
you to cross operating systems.
These are all things that we
want to ensure your ability
to do because we know you have
a very diverse set of needs,
and it's not just about one
tool, one device, one platform.
We also think through
this to ensure
that we want you to have a
very seamless experience when
you deploy this.
Even though we have minimum
consistency from a security
perspective, we
also want to ensure
that when you're going out
and going into the ecosystem
to procure your devices,
to procure services,
we want to make sure that you
feel comfortable that they
actually understand
Android Enterprise
and can help you be successful.
So we developed a program called
Android Enterprise Recommended
that begins to span
that value chain.
You now know when you
go purchase a device,
it's recommended.
It's certified by Google.
You now know that when you
go into an EMM or a UEM,
we've also certified
that, as well.
So all the controls and
security that we talk about
are now leveragable by
you as an organization
through these tools
that we've reviewed
and partner with quite
closely within the ecosystem.
So now when you
purchase and you try
to think through an
end-to-end solution,
you now have certification
across the entire ecosystem
so that you don't have to
worry about validating that
within your own organization.
So with that, I want
to introduce Nisha.
She's thought through a
lot of these situations
in her experience
with Accenture.
What we've talked
about quite a bit
now are things that have been
happening in the recent past,
as well as what people
are going through today.
Obviously, in her
role at Accenture,
she now is able to think
through things even beyond that,
think what happens
in a world when
you go beyond just
having mobility
and you go beyond
just cloud computing.
How does this actually transform
the business and the world
that we live in?
We want to be sure
that you actually
have an understanding
of that so you
can contextualize the broad
as well as the near-term.
Thank you very much.
NISHA SHARMA: Thanks, Eugene.
EUGENE YEH: Yep.
NISHA SHARMA: Hi, everyone.
I'm Nisha Sharma.
I'm a managing director
at Accenture Digital.
I've actually been at Accenture
for about 20 years now,
and about 15 of those years have
been in the enterprise mobility
space, so the very early days
of mobile, which I'm sure many
of you can remember.
So it's been quite fascinating
to see how mobility has changed
over the course of this time.
And what I wanted to do was
spend some time talking to you
about what's next.
What are the trends
that we are seeing
within technology, within our
solutions, and the kind of work
that we're doing
with our clients now?
So every year, Accenture
releases our Technology Vision.
We just released our most recent
2019 Tech Vision in February.
And the Tech Vision
talks about, again,
what are some of the trends that
we are seeing in the business?
Not just technology
trends, but trends
that are impacting
the kind of work
that our clients are doing.
And so I thought I'd
spend a little bit
of time sharing that with you
so you can understand where
mobility fits,
where Android fits,
and the kinds of things that
we are doing in this space
because it's changing quite
quickly, and you'll see that.
So just to kind
of set the stage,
the digital era
technology that we've been
talking about all this time--
it's expected now
from every business.
In fact, in 2018, companies
spent $1.1 trillion
on digital
transformation projects,
and 94% of organizations
say that they're
doing digital
transformation work already.
So it's just expected.
So what's next?
If everybody's doing this,
what are the next types
of things that we're working on?
And we call this now
the post-digital era.
And again, the
digital technologies--
it doesn't mean that
digital is over.
It's certainly not the case.
It just means that digital
is just expected to be there.
It's the price of admission.
We don't say anymore--
we don't ask, well,
if you have a mobile
phone, then do this.
It's just, on your
mobile phone, do this.
So it's just assumed
that you have this.
So we're starting to see a
new set of characteristics
that are defining what this
post-digital era looks like.
And some of those things are
around individualization,
as an example.
It's about knowing
what our users want.
It's not just
personalization, but it's
almost hyper-personalization.
OK.
I know you like these things, or
you've done things around this,
but it's really
understanding what you want
and what you need.
It's also around
instant on-demand.
So yeah, OK, we know what you
want, but you want it now.
You need it now.
So how do we get these
services to you in that way?
We also talk about
momentary markets,
how it's almost this
pop-up-like environment.
And I'll give you this
example of some work
that we've been doing with
Carnival Cruise Lines.
They're transforming the
entire ship experience.
And I don't know if anybody's
been on a recent Carnival
Cruise experience, but
what they're doing now
is everybody gets a
medallion, they call it.
It's a wearable device.
So this medallion
knows your preferences,
it knows where you
are on the ship,
it knows what you're
doing, and all of that.
It allows you to buy things.
It's like that.
And in addition to that,
they've got sensors
all around the ship.
The cruise employees all have
mobile devices with them.
And they've got all this
analytics and everything just
all around the ship.
So the idea is that
let's say there's
an attraction, like
a show or something,
and they realize that based
on everything that they know,
that there's an upcoming
attraction that perhaps
your child might be
interested in going,
that you know that
they want to go to.
So now they can just send
you a message saying,
hey, I've reserved
a spot for you.
Would you like to attend this?
Or would you like to
purchase this ticket to go?
And it gives you
that opportunity.
So it's very momentary.
It's just, hey, you
weren't planning this,
but this opportunity came up.
I'd like to give you the
opportunity to buy this,
and then it's done.
So that's what we mean
by momentary markets.
And the other characteristic
is around trust
and responsibility.
We're just expecting trust
from all of our providers.
So much data is being collected
and being available about us,
and so it's just expected
that in this new world,
that companies are treating
our data responsibly and making
sure that we understand,
also, how they're using it.
So what I want to
do is take a look
at some of the trends that
are in the Tech Vision.
Now, there are five trends
that we talk about overall,
but I'd like to really
focus on three of them
because I think they are
most impacting the space
around enterprise mobility.
And it'll show you what's
happening in the enterprise
world.
Some of the other
trends are more around
the consumer experience
and what we're
seeing in the consumer world.
But I thought I'd start
with the enterprise side.
So the first trend is called
DARQ power-- "dark" with a Q.
And we'll go through
each of these,
but it's Distributed Ledgers,
Artificial Intelligence,
Extended Reality, and
Quantum Computing.
These are basically the
new wave of technologies
that we're seeing
our clients use now.
So the D is for
distributed ledgers.
We're using technologies
like blockchain,
and cryptocurrencies, and
these types of things.
We're using them in
our supply chains
to have end-to-end trusted
transactions and such.
We have carmakers who are
using blockchain technologies
to protect cars from hackers.
We have delivery
companies, like DHL
for example, who
are using blockchain
to ensure that perhaps some
medication that you ordered
is the correct medication,
and it's not counterfeit,
and following it along the way.
So we're seeing the uses of
those types of technologies.
The A is for artificial
intelligence.
I'm sure you've seen so
many examples of some really
cool artificial intelligence
and machine learning
types of implementations,
even here at Next.
In fact, at our booth,
we have the robot--
if you've seen the robotic arm
that is taking Petri dishes
and putting them under
a camera for analysis
and is using image
recognition to check
the quality of those
samples, and then it's
got the new IoT Edge
TPU incorporated
in that to accelerate
that kind of processing.
But so there's a lot that's
happening in the AI space
around image recognition,
natural language processing,
and so on and so on.
In fact, I think
67% of businesses
say that they're
already exploring
artificial intelligence
in some ways today.
The R is for extended reality--
XR.
That's augmented
reality, virtual reality,
mixed realities, assisted
reality, so on and so on.
And this is all about
new experiences.
It's about new ways of training.
We're now providing our
workers with headsets
that allow them to
virtualize environments
so that they can train and learn
in those places, as an example.
New ways of shopping
I'm sure you've seen.
I mean, you take
your phone and you
can augment some product
that's out there,
or be able to interact
with some product,
perhaps, in a virtual way.
New ways of exploring
places for education
and so on, just to be
able to virtually see
in a national park, or a
museum, or someplace like that.
Then the Q is for
quantum computing.
It seems like quantum
computing is far out,
but we actually are working
with some of our clients
now to explore how
quantum computing can
be used to solve some difficult
problems that they perhaps
weren't able to solve before.
We worked with a
company called 1QBit,
if you're familiar with them.
But we mapped out
over 150 different use
cases for quantum computing--
things like drug discovery,
or route optimization,
or fraud detection, and
those types of scenarios.
So individually,
these are definitely
opportunities for
differentiation
in this new world.
And then when you
put them together,
you really, really start to
see some new, even unimagined,
possibilities around what
we can do in the future.
So we talked about the future,
and these are not way out
future trends.
These are actually
already happening now.
89% of businesses say
that they're already
experimenting with one
or more of these types
of DARQ technologies.
And businesses are
expecting big impacts
from these technologies.
Just as an example,
41% of executives
rank AI as the
technology that they
expect to have the most
impact in their organization
over the next three years.
So people are doing this,
and it's happening now.
But again, like I
said, that doesn't
mean that everything we've done
with the digital technologies
is done.
In fact, we're expecting
that those are the foundation
for these new technologies.
So we talk about here this
move from SMAC to DARQ.
Have you all heard of SMAC--
Social, Mobile, Analytics,
and Cloud technologies.
And up until now, that's the
kind of work we had been doing.
We had been using social
media technologies.
We've been rolling
out mobile devices.
Maybe not those 41% of
companies that you mentioned,
Eugene, but companies
really are using
these, both in the
consumer space,
but also in the
enterprise space.
And then cloud and analytics,
and just again as an example,
as we move to these dark
technologies, mobile is just--
it's the front-end.
It's the channel that
people will be using.
It's just expected to be there.
And we'll talk
about that, as well.
Again, just another example,
that 92% percent of companies
there say that their SMAC
technologies are still
considered to be a
competitive differentiation.
But we are moving past
that and establishing
that as a foundation,
and it's only
going to allow us to take
our businesses in the future.
And the whole idea, really, is
that if you're not doing these,
if you haven't already
done the SMAC technologies,
it's going to be harder for
you to keep up, especially
as we're moving very, very
quickly into the future.
As we all know, the
pace of innovation,
the pace of technology
changes is just
continuing to
accelerate all the time.
So just using the
mobility example here,
so we talked about
XR, extended reality.
And this example is just
showing that virtual reality
and augmented reality
solutions are all
built on mobile devices.
You need a mobile device.
You need the network
communication.
You need to have applications
that are built to support this,
and they're all running
on mobile devices, just as
an example.
So the next trend I want to talk
about is what we call Human+.
So again, talking about what
is impacting our enterprises,
well, this is about
our workforce.
And what we're seeing
is that 90% of jobs
that we currently
have today, we know
that they're going to change
as a result of AI, robotics,
and other such technologies.
So jobs are changing fast.
And what we're seeing is that--
what we know is that
individuals, as workers,
we of course come with our
skills and with our knowledge,
but we are also becoming human+
in that we are enabled even
further by technology that our
companies are providing to us
to do our work.
And I'll show you a couple
of examples of that.
But the point is that as
this workforce evolves,
our companies need
to keep up with that
and be able to provide the
employees with the tools
that they want and need
in order to do their jobs.
So a couple of examples
here just to highlight.
We have an oil and gas company
whose workers right now have
mobile devices and
mobile technologies
to help them
troubleshoot issues that
are a mile underground
with these new game-like
visualization tools that have
been developed for them to do
that troubleshooting.
We have factories where
humans and robots are working
side-by-side in the
factories to do the work,
and we have AI tools
that are helping
to identify which
types of jobs should be
done by which types of workers.
We have workers who are being
trained as drone delivery
pilots.
These are jobs that
never existed before.
But again, they
would be able to use
the technology and the
applications and such
that their workers have
that their employers have
given them to be able to
work with these drones,
and analyze what's
coming from them,
and be able to support
the work in those ways.
But when it comes
to what companies
need to be thinking about in
order to support their workers,
we're really looking
at three areas
and these are around hiring,
training, and knowledge
management.
So if you think
about it from hiring,
when it comes to these changing
jobs, this changing workforce,
it's getting harder and
harder to find the people who
have these skills already.
And so companies are shifting
the normal approaches
that they would
use to hire people.
So they're moving
away from these more
kind of reactive skills-based
hiring approaches,
not just like putting out a
job description that says,
I need someone who has three
years of accounting experience.
They're not looking at
it that way anymore.
Now, as an example, Unilever--
one of the things
that they're doing
is they're actually
screening candidates
with a series of games.
So imagine they've
got all these apps
and such that have
these games on them,
and they're assessing
their memory.
They're assessing their
acceptance of risk.
They're looking
at whether they're
more likely to read
contextual or emotional cues.
So they're trying to
understand how you work,
rather than what you know.
And then they're using AI
tools to review those results
and match these
candidates with open jobs.
So again, another
example of we're
providing applications
on mobile devices
to allow the employers to do
these sorts of assessments.
On the training side,
again, companies
can't hire fast enough in
terms of the kinds of jobs
that we need skills for.
And so there's a need to invest
in reskilling and providing
on-demand training opportunities
for our existing workforce.
This survey says that
43% of businesses
say that 60% of
their workforce will
move into new roles over
the next three years.
So how do we provide our
workers with the training
that they need?
And this is again
being done with mobile
because they're on the go.
They're just moving,
and we're really
finding new ways of
providing training options
to our employees.
And the third area's around
knowledge management.
So we have more
information available to us
than we ever have before,
but it's harder and harder
to find and access
this information
because people are
moving around quickly
and it's just hard to capture.
So we're using new technologies,
like natural language
processing, as a way to
capture this information
and be able to access it.
We're looking at things
like indexing unstructured
documents, such as an incident
report or something like that,
so we can find the
information we need there.
We're looking at
knowledge graphs
to be able to search a wide
variety of data sources.
And so again, we're looking
at really changing our tools
that we've been
using for so long
to be able to use
them in new ways.
So I think another
point, as well,
when it comes to
hiring and training,
one of the things that
businesses are also looking at
is the new generation
of workers that
are coming into the workforce.
They're being forced
to look at, what
are the tools and technologies
that they're already
using in the world, and
recognizing in our world today,
the majority of people
have Android devices.
And so companies are looking--
OK, well, let's take
advantage of that.
Let's build on these Android
experiences and the Android
devices that they have to
be able to provide them
with the same types
of experiences
that they're used to, or even
tools like G Suite, where I'm
sure you've seen that
in schools and colleges,
students are using G Suite.
So how do we build these
new tools and capabilities
on things that they
already know, and they're
comfortable with, and they like,
rather than thinking of, oh,
what are those old-school,
more traditional tools,
they really have to think
about these in new ways.
So the third trend that
I wanted to talk about
is secure us to secure me.
This is all about security.
And the point here is that
security is no longer just
about protecting one's self,
it's about protecting everyone.
And we can't, as a business--
it still typically
sees cybersecurity
as an individual effort,
meaning that if I
secure my own systems,
if I secure my own data,
then I'll be safe.
But that's really not the
case because as businesses,
we are part of a
broader ecosystem, now,
of technology partners
that we're working with.
And every technology, every
solution, every application,
no matter where
it's coming from,
can be exposed to
vulnerabilities in some way.
And so you can't just
assume that, OK, well,
you guys have it covered.
You have to work together in
this new world to do that.
In fact, the survey point
there says that only 29%
of executives actually know that
their ecosystem partners are
working just as diligently
as they would expect
to in regards to security.
Now, we're seeing new types of
risks or coming up in new ways
around the whole misuse of data.
Normally, we think
that if someone
gets unauthorized
access to my data, well,
then they're going to use
that to exploit something
in my system.
But in reality, what's happening
is you can find this data,
you can find data in
some other system that's
totally unrelated to you, but
use it somehow to infiltrate
or get into your own systems.
So the attackers are
really now seeing
this ecosystem as an
ever-widening attack surface.
Another example is
around aggregated data.
We think of aggregated data
as being somewhat anonymized,
or can't necessarily tell
who, identify individuals,
or something like that.
But we've seen cases
where there was
an example of some aggregated
data that was found on Strava
and then used out of context
to identify some secret US
military sites.
So in today's connected
and ecosystem world,
the impact of cyber
attacks is just
being exponentially amplified.
And you might remember
though the WannaCry crypto
worm that happened.
That was where someone
exposed an operating system
vulnerability and attacked
300,000 computers over 150
countries in just a few days.
And that brought down
all sorts of businesses
and impacted our
work tremendously.
There was the Mirai malware that
hijacked 100,000 IoT devices,
and then they use that to
launch an attack on a domain
registration services provider.
So there's these
downstream impacts
and all sorts of impacts that
we have as a result of us
being in this world.
And what I think
businesses are realizing
is that as they collaborate
with their ecosystem partners
on new services, and new
products, and new experiences,
they also really need to be
collaborating on security, as
well.
And there's no doubt that
Google, with Android and Google
Cloud, are a part of this
right, because the foundation
of a lot of what we do
is on our mobile device.
And as employees,
as consumers, we
don't necessarily know exactly
where something went wrong.
It's like, oh, something
happened on my phone.
And people will just
think of, OK, it's
an Android problem or whatever.
But that's why Google and
the Android Enterprise team
have been doing so
much to try to protect
the experience on
the phones, not
just, I have to protect my piece
here, but recognize their role
in this ecosystem
and in the solutions
that we're providing
to everyone,
and doing what they
can to protect us.
Again, to protect everyone,
not just as individuals.
So yeah, so I think these
are just some of the trends
that I wanted to highlight
for you just to give you
a glimpse of what's
happening out there
as you think about the future
and how we can continue
to use mobile, and how it is
such a foundation for what
we are doing.
These are the other trends here.
If you want to learn more,
you can visit our site,
accenture.com/technologyvision,
but yeah, hopefully that helps.
So Eugene?
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]